the headlines are scary but here's the
truth about shark attacks while sharks
live on every coast of the United States
even Alaska the chances of being killed
by a shark is one in 3.7 million that's
a low number you're more likely to die
by drowning a dog attack or even the
lightning strike now the chances of
encountering a shark do increase the
more time you hang out on its turf just
like hiking in the woods increases your
chances of seeing a bear most shark
attack victims are surfers and other
board enthusiasts followed by swimmers
and snorkelers but when you consider
that collectively people enter the ocean
15 billion times each year and up those
only 50 to 100 shark encounters take
place those are pretty good odds in mole
visibility we look like shark prey which
is to say fish and all that splashing
around just gets their attention the
stories of these menacing fish and their
toothy weapons are enough to send
everyone in a panic but let's keep
everything in perspective there's going
to be a spike in shark attacks in the
summer when we swarm the beaches
increasing the likelihood of meeting a
shark because most sharks are
cold-blooded
they prefer warmer waters but even in
the warmest of waters the odds of a
shark attacking you are almost
non-existent still scared beach goers
like yourself can practice the following
tips to avoid attracting sharks and
here's something to chew on for every
human killed by a shark humans kill
millions of sharks
bottom line the chances that you'll ever
have a dangerous encounter with a shark
over the course of your life it's just
about zero no matter where you are or
what you are doing in the water